a few months ago I understood suddenly
how thought was just an illusory thing
and how
thought is responsible for if not all
most of the suffering we experience and
then I suddenly felt
like I was looking at these thoughts
from another perspective and I wondered
who is it it's aware that I'm thinking
and suddenly I was thrown into this
expansive amazing feeling of freedom
from myself from my problems I saw that
I was bigger than what I do I was bigger
than my body I was everything and
everyone I was no longer a fragment of
the universe I was the universe and ever
since that day I've been trying to get
back there
[Music]
hey Nick I made it man did you want to
share him you said tonight I knew you'd
come
I saw it in your eyes man you're gonna
lob there what's up Terrence is a genius
he's gonna blow your mind all over the
goddamn room he's like a freakin mind
grenade not sure I want that yeah
history has these Dominator types by the
ball and lava you know history history
is a psychedelic experience if it's the
collective unfolding of the dream of our
species and space and time and we are at
the apex this is the piece this is the
second hour of the trip we're going over
the top
[Applause]